Jim Whitaker: I grew up on a family farm.
My family's been farming for 130 years
in southeast Arkansas,
and I'm a fifth generation farmer.
We raise cotton, rice, corn and soybeans,
along with my brother Sam,
our extended families
and a lot of great coworkers,
could not do it without them.
So when I was 16 years old,
I came home from school one day.
It was my dad's birthday.
My birthday was three days later.
I expected in some type of party event.
But my dad had just went through
the historic 1980 drought,
and when I got home that day,
my mom was crying,
my dad was trying to console her,
and there's a foreclosure
letter on the bar.
We thought we were going
to lose the family farm
that we had had in our family
for generations.
Luckily, we did not lose the farm,
but he still struggled financially.
When I was 22 years old,
after a little time in the army,
I decided I was going to start farming.
So my brother and I rented a farm.
My dad couldn't help us,
he didn't have the finances.
He could not help us get started.
Farming is very
capital-intensive business.
And so we got an FHA
beginning farmer loan.
And let me tell you something
about renting a farm
when you're 22 years old.
No one rents you a farm
unless no one else wants to rent it.
(Laughter)
It was a big piece of land,
it was cash rent.
I mean, the stakes were set.
We were doomed to fail.
And we weren't focused on environmental
sustainability back then.
We were focused
on economic sustainability.
How do we make higher yield,
how do we use less fertilizer?
How do we get to the next year
and feed our family?
And ...
It happens that economic and environmental
sustainability go hand in hand
along with social sustainability.
As we used less fertilizer,
used less water,
our yields started going up.
It was just a great thing.
So one of the first things
we did on our rice fields,
we adopted a technique
that's a little different.
We leveled our fields completely flat.
This is called zero-grade.
Rice all over the world
is grown in a flooded environment.
Everywhere.
And most people use
the natural contour of the Earth
to cascade the water down
and let the water flow downhill.
And there are always,
we call it continuous flood.
They continuously
put water on their fields.
And we leveled ours flat
with a perimeter road.
And what that perimeter road
lets us do is capture rainfall.
So we actually pump less water,
we are able to use less water,
we have less runoff, less erosion,
less nutrients leaving our field.
Nothing leaves our field
unless we want it to.
So I get around farmers
and I tell them about potential
carbon credits and other things,
and our family was lucky,
we were one of the first ever in the world
to sell agricultural carbon credits
in 2016 to Microsoft using this protocol
that we've designed on rice.
And I got that --
Let me just back up a little bit
and tell you how I got that.
I didn't get that on my own.
I met two very instrumental people.
One was Dr. Merle Anders.
He is the world-renowned
greenhouse gas expert,
and he started mentoring me.
The other was a buyer from Mars Foods,
and we were in a leadership
class together.
And we started talking and we started
thinking about sustainability.
So that's how my journey started.
But you know, when I tell other farmers
that they could potentially
sell carbon credit,
they could help companies reduce
their scope 3 emissions,
they could save money,
possibly enroll in environmental
climate-smart practices
for the government,
they say, "I'm just trying to get by."
Farming is a generational business.
People have been doing things,
passed down father to son, father to son.
And you'll see, father
to daughter, here in a minute.
It's passed down generationally,
and we only get one chance a year
to make a mistake.
So when you tell people about doing things
that are outside their norm,
it scares the heck out of them.
So I found a different way
of talking to them about it.
I say, "Well, you know,
you could save 40 to 50 dollars
on your pumping cost.
You could sell a carbon credit.
You could get paid more
by a company for doing the right thing."
This starts to pique their interest.
Risk mitigation is how we're going
to get farmers involved.
We are a for-profit industry,
so they're not going to do anything
that they think hurts their yields.
So Jessica,
went to college, got a business degree,
a sustainability minor,
went on to get her MBA,
emphasis on finance.
Now she's back helping me.
Not all the time on the family farm.
She works for Ducks Unlimited,
one of the most aggressive
conservationists in the rice industry.
They are an awesome partner to work with.
She's back working with Ducks Unlimited,
but she's been helping me with protocols
and data collection.
One of the things
that I wanted to figure out was,
number one: What’s important?
How are we going to quantify it?
And then how are we going
to sell that data?
Because everyone here wants to know,
"Can we have your data?"
No, you can't.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Anyway, so we're trying to figure out
how to quantify that.
So we established what is called
the Smart Rice protocol.
We partner with a global
seed company, RiceTec,
and we have one of the first ever --
there's a couple more --
I promise you it's the most rigorous,
but we have one of the first ever
third-party verified,
sustainable rice packages
that hit the market a few months ago,
and we’re trying to get
in retail locations.
And then we’re also helping some major
end users with their scope 3.
And I think that's going to be the future.
But Jessica's role in growing rice
is much different than mine,
and she's part of the next generation
to come take over our family farm.
(Applause)
Jessica Whitaker Allen:
I'm a sixth generation farmer.
Growing up, I remember
running around outside barefoot,
catching as many snakes,
turtles, frogs as possible,
and then trying to convince my parents
to let me keep them inside as pets.
(Laughter)
Eventually, my dad bought me an aquarium,
and we had fun with that
for a little while inside
until a few of the snakes
got lost in our house
and we never found them.
Sorry.
(Laughter)
We live and work in southeast Arkansas.
McGehee, specifically.
Our town has 4,000 residents
and one stoplight.
The nearest airport, Starbucks,
shopping mall, Whole Foods,
is two hours away in any direction.
Without places like this
and farmers like us,
you'd be hungry, naked and sober.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
I sometimes jokingly say
that I have three,
sometimes four full-time jobs,
but I really have three
or four full-time jobs.
My day job is as a conservation
coordinator with Ducks Unlimited
under the Rice Stewardship Partnership.
I work alongside rice farmers to protect,
restore and manage wetlands for waterfowl.
Waterfowl spend a lot of time
in rice fields, by the way.
I’m also a wife, mother,
and I do anything and everything I can
for our family farm.
The last one doesn't pay the bills,
but it's hard to say no to my dad.
So when he sent me an email
about a grant he was interested in
a little over a year ago, I got to work.
My dad releases the butterflies
and I have to catch them.
I have to figure out
how to do what's going on,
whatever is in his mind.
He's the thinker, I'm the doer.
This grant specifically
was the USDA's partnerships
for climate-smart commodities.
I submitted a proposal
on behalf of our farm,
and it was successfully selected.
We are going to work with farmers
in southeast Arkansas
to educate them about the benefits
of growing sustainable rice.
We're going to work
with veterans, immigrants,
limited-resource and socially
disadvantaged farmers.
Farmers that aren't so different
from my family just a few generations ago.
We will then implement pay-for-practices
such as alternate wetting and drying,
cover crop, no till and low till.
We will then help them learn about
and document their
greenhouse gas benefits.
Monitor, measure, report and verify them.
Then market and sell
that rice, at a premium,
to help them realize the benefits
of producing sustainable rice.
The economic advantage.
I'm a farmer, but not
in the way you might think.
I don’t drive the tractors,
and I don’t plant the rice.
But I know how to take
what my dad has learned
and what he is doing
and share that with others.
I know how to interpret the data
and see the reduction in inputs
that has both an economic
and an environmental impact.
I don't know if that alone is enough
to stop climate change,
but I'm surrounded by farmers
that are doing everything they can
to be more sustainable.
I think my brother and I
will take over the farm someday
if my dad lets us.
And hopefully when my son is old enough,
I'll take him out on the farm
and show him what I do.
I'll tell him he can go do
whatever he wants to do,
and hopefully one day I'll see him
back on the farm,
the seventh generation.
But for that to happen,
we need a sustainable farming industry,
one that rewards trailblazers
and early adopters
instead of penalizing them.
Farmers like my family
who are on the front lines
of sustainable rice production.
JW: So Jessica mentioned
alternate wetting and drying.
And I think in my haste, I left it out.
So let me tell you what it is.
It is when we flood a rice field
continuously, like my dad taught us,
we put four inches of water on it.
We have an evaporation rate
of about a quarter inch a day,
so we have about 16 days
of available water.
Rice is an anaerobic crop.
It's grown in flooded conditions.
When the soil starts to dry,
the microbial community goes dormant,
and the field stops emitting
methane emissions.
Let me tell you why that's important.
There are 400 million acres
of rice grown globally.
It is the largest emitter of methane gas.
It is the largest user
of irrigation water,
and our methods, if used, can reduce
greenhouse gas by 50 percent,
reduce water use by 50 percent,
increase yields to feed a hungry world.
(Applause)
JWA: If our protocols
were adopted more widely,
can you imagine the benefits?
If you take care of the planet,
it will take care of you.
That's true for farmers and for all of us.
Farmers take care of consumers,
take care of all of you every single day.
It's time for you to start
taking care of farmers.
Thank you.
JW: Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)